Hunter Biden showed up and this is great
hunter Biden first showed up to the
capital some weeks ago but he wouldn't
go in he didn't want to actually testify
he just held a big press conference
outside this time he's gone in he still
won't go to the closed door testimony
that he's required to do but he shows up
and he says he'll he'll speak publicly
and the Republicans go after him in kind
of strange ways chairman comr um first
of all my first question is who brought
Biden to be here today that's my first
question um second question you are the
epitome of white privilege coming into
the oversight committee spitting in our
face ignoring a congressional subpoena
to be deposed what are you afraid of you
have no balls to come up here and Mr
chairman point of inquiry Mr chairman um
the recogniz if the G if the G lady
wants to hear from Hunter Biden we can
hear from him right now Mr chairman
let's take a vote and hear from Hunter
Biden what are you afraid of to hold on
hold on
order are women allowed to speak in here
or no are women allowed to speak in here
or no if you keep interrupting me I I'll
interrupt the chair I don't know that
he's a
lady I think that uh that Hunter Biden
should be arrested right here right now
and go straight to jail our nation is
founded on the rule of
law this is so
depressing it's so depressing because
this is the Republican this is the
conservative and she's got this
opportunity to really go after Hunter
Biden the bagman for the Biden family
that this guy who is the tip of the
Spear of Biden corruption and the way
she does it is by regurgitating a bunch
of far-left talking
points what are her attacks on Hunter
Biden are her attacks that he's a derel
who behaves in a in a vicious way who's
faced no consequences for his personal
crimes and that he is the representative
ative of the major political crimes of
his family his father who pedal American
influence all around the world and
profited from it is that it no her
attack is you're a white man you white
man you have white privilege Hunter
Biden does not have white privilege if
Hunter Biden had white privilege then
when he applied to college he would have
been discriminated against by the
admissions board he would have lost
effectively lost points on his SAT score
because of the color of his skin if
Hunter Biden had
privilege he would have been excoriated
he would have been punished more harshly
for transgressions he hasn't been
punished at all he would have been
regularly uh reviled and insulted not
only as a a matter of of law but even as
a matter
of social norms because white people are
the only people in the country that you
are permitted legally to discriminate
against and and also encouraged socially
to discriminate
against okay White Privilege are you
kidding me this is what we this is what
we get for electing Republicans and
conservatives we get to hear invectives
about the evil white man from Congress
oh great with Republicans like this who
needs Democrats and then when they
rightly tell her yo lady give it a rest
she says are women not allowed to talk
so then she she flips she she stops
pushing the race hustling uh
phrases of the left and she switches to
the feminist phrases of the left I'm a
woman and the men aren't letting me
speak vote for Republicans so you can
get more girl boss feminist talking
points in Congress oh oh it's so it's so
pathetic it's awful it's
awful
ah what
a what a what a black pill as the kids
call it this is this and why is this
happening
because liberalism is the water in which
we little fish swim liberalism is the
air that we breathe it's because we
become so habituated to the language of
the left that we internalize it and it
doesn't just Lodge itself in some corner
of our brain it actually forms our
Consciousness in the way that we
perceive the world it's because if you
can control words you can control minds
as I point out in my number one
bestselling book speechless controlling
words controlling Minds available now
for for order even a couple of years
after it was published I I think this is
proof positive it's just so of all the
things to attack Hunter Biden
for being a white guy is pretty low on
the list and of all the reasons to
complain about the way Congress
operates to say it's because we don't
let women speak enough oh good grief
Lady it's just awful now Margery Taylor
green had a better line of questioning
against Hunter Biden uh so much so that
he stormed out of the capital chair
recognize Miss Green from Georgia for
five
minutes thank you Mr chairman uh excuse
me Hunter apparently you're afraid of my
words
here
oh I like to reclaim my time Mr chairman
burst their
bubble wow that's too
bad CH recognizes M from I think it's
clear and obvious for everyone watching
this hearing today that Hunter Biden is
terrified of strong Conservative
Republican women because he can't even
face my words as I was about to speak to
him what a coward even margerie I don't
want to knock her too much for this even
margorie starts to take on these
feminist talking points and she is Far
and Away the best Republican in this
exchange but even she even you got Nancy
mace who does the white men are evil and
I'm a girl boss and women aren't heard
and this is a patriarchy and she even
she uses naughty language like you know
I'm not a regular Congress lady I'm a
cool Congress lady I'm going to use
naughty vulgar language that if a
seventh grader used it in a classroom
he'd be yelled at but me I'm cool so I'm
going to break all Norms of Civility
yeah I'm cool doesn't that make me cool
I'm like cool like a liberal but I'm a
conservative but I'm actually a liberal
and margorie Taylor green doesn't really
engage in a lot of that but even there
at the end he's afraid of strong women
no he's afraid of going to prison and
getting caught for being The Bag Man for
the family and pedling American
influence and making tens of millions of
dollars that's that's what he's afraid
of he's not afraid of women that man
Hunter Biden might be afraid of a lot of
stuff he ain't afraid of women have you
looked at the tapes okay we've seen the
videotapes from the laptop it's just so
ah it's just so divorced from reality
and who does this work on who is this
supposed to work on nobody really
believes this stuff we all March along
and and and many people will will spout
off the talking points of white
privilege and feminism and patriarchy
but it's it's just because it's been
drilled into our head since we were in
kindergarten it doesn't actually stir
men's souls or anything like that it
certainly doesn't persuade people on the
right stop using the Liberals language
I'm I'm actually lauding margorie Taylor
green here I I think it was a good
exchange but guys cut it out with the
feminist liberal White Privilege blah
blah blah clap trap just drop it good
grief
the best exchange with Hunter was Far
and Away not with any of the members of
Congress it was it was with a reporter
who asked a question that was on all of
our minds let me make a statement crack
you normally smoke
Mr this is how Hunter Biden should be
dealt with on Capitol Hill okay Hunter
Biden is showing up to Capitol Hill not
to answer the legitimate questions of
congress not not to face consequences
for his crimes that have been caught on
tape for years and years and
years some of which are not just Petty
personal sexual crimes and Drug crimes
but but actually pretty serious
political crimes he is there to try to
win public sympathy he is there to make
the case that he's actually a victim of
a Witch Hunt he's there to to move the
poles and so knowing that understanding
that that's what this is really about
the way to deal with Hunter Biden is to
give as good as as as he does
okay the way to deal with Hunter Biden
is say hey hey man what's your favorite
kind of crack huh oh you think that's an
unfair question then come over here and
answer my fair
questions hey since we're all just
Jokers here today right no one's
actually going to be undertaking a
serious Congressional proceeding so I
yeah what's your who what's your
favorite kind of hooker Hunter what do
you wh what's your favorite form of
currency do you like are you a big fan
do you like the Chinese currency or the
Ukrainian currency more because you made
millions of both so what which what do
you like what's your favorite oh you
okay you didn't well then let's talk
let's go into your financial disclosures
let's go into all the shell
corporations let's go into your business
associates meeting with your father when
he was vice president of the United
States let's go into your father being
on 20 plus phone calls with the with the
business men you were shaking down all
around the world oh no we're not going
to do that okay well what what how long
how long do you like the crack pipes to
be do you like them to be 2 in or 4 in
love it absolutely great hilarious
exchange and it precisely the degree of
seriousness that that proceeding merits
man what a great clip that was now hold
up hold up hold up hold up all my fellas
who be saying we soft ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael NS YouTube
channel see you next time